madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans cette
édition lyonnais je suis pas prise à
partie à ramallah en cisjordanie le
premier ministre attaqué à coups de
pierres par plusieurs dizaines de
manifestants
jacques chirac se dit choquée par ces
incidents regrettables les réactions
politiques se multiplient
le premier ministre attendue à paris
dans moins d'une heure et qui devrait
rencontrer le président de la république
mais selon quel calendrier la question
est posée
terrible accident dans le gard un groupe
de cyclotouristes fauchée par un
chauffard 4 mort 17 blessés la vitesse
excessive serait à l'origine de ce drame
à la veille de l'ouverture du salon de
l'agriculture à paris avec pour thème la
sécurité alimentaire des français les
derniers préparatifs et le concours
général la soirée des [ __ ] sur
france 2 l'esprit de coluche toujours
présent pour ce quinzième anniversaire
de la fondation des restos du coeur les
coulisses et des répétitions dans ce
journal avant le spectacle au zénith
diffusé après ce journal l'essentiel de
l'actualité de ce samedi dominée par
cette flambée de violence qui a
accompagné ce matin la visite de lionel
jospin en cisjordanie le ressentiment
des étudiants palestiniens et la fureur
de dizaines de manifestants à ramallah
autour de l'université protestant contre
les déclarations jugées
pro-palestinienne du premier ministre
s'est transformé en une véritable
attaque à coups de pierres contre le
cortège le chef du gouvernement français
et les ministres qui l'accompagnaient
sont sortis indemnes de ces incidents
qui viennent s'ajouter aux remous
diplomatiques qui ont émaillé le séjour
de lionel jospin sur place notre
correspondant permanent
charles enderlin lionel jospin via de
terminer sa rencontre avec des
enseignants il doit regagner sa voiture
première erreur de la sécurité il passe
par la manifestation au lieu d'emprunter
l'autre issue plus discrète
il faut dire que les responsables de
l'université avaient reçu la promesse
des dirigeants estudiantin qu'il n'y
aurait pas de violence
ces tracts sont signées par le front
islamique
et voici les premières pierres
à
les gardes du corps français et
palestinien protège
lionel jospin
messieurs bédrines sauter et gayssot qui
accompagne le premier ministre sont
emmenés de côté par leurs gardes du
corps
nabil chaath le ministre palestinien de
la coopération internationale et poussé
dans la voiture par amir el poussé ni
son chef de sécurité
les manifestants parviennent jusqu'au
véhicule qui n'est plus garder
les pierres rebondissent sur les vitres
blindées
des étudiants islamistes mais aussi
d'autres factions palestiniennes
participe à la tac
courageusement ils brême créé chien
l'ancien président du conseil étudiant
monte sur le toit de la voiture pour
tenter d'arrêter l'émeute
il est rejoint par mohamed longue date
et abdallah al khateeb qui sera blessé
en direct de jérusalem charles enderlin
la tension était palpable ce matin et on
a du mal à comprendre comment et
pourquoi le premier ministre a pu
facilement devenir la cible de dizaines
de manifestants apparemment un système
de protection étaient plus que
défaillant et alors sur les événements
de ce matin je crois que les images
parlent d'elles mêmes alors s'il s'agit
de déterminer les responsabilités
vous devez savoir que l'université de
bir zeït se trouve en zone b sécurité
israéliennes administration
palestinienne normalement l'armée
israélienne ne rentre pas dans
l'université il y aurait les accrochages
autrement plus sanglant
mais l'autorité palestinienne s'il ya
une visite importante dans l'université
a la possibilité de demander aux
israéliens
l'autorisation de déployer des gars de
la sécurité supplémentaires d'après
l'armée israélienne
il n'y a pas eu une telle demande je
n'ai pas la réaction de l'autorité
palestinienne et puis les responsables
de l'université de birzeit n'ont
visiblement pas réalisé que le tel
événement risque et d'arrivée ne se fait
pas de souci il avait la promesse des
étudiants qui n'auraient pas de violence
et puis après tout la france contribue
largement au budget de l'université de
bir zeït la faculté de droit où se
trouvait monsieur jospin a reçu 2
millions de francs quelles sont les
mesures prises par les palestiniens ce
soir alors yasser arafat est très en
colère il se considère comme un ami de
monsieur jospin il a donné des ordres
pour que l affaire soit réglée dans les
48 heures il ya déjà une quinzaine
d'arrestations
le colonel radio qui commande la
sécurité palestinienne pour la
cisjordanie était à bir zeït une heure
après les incidents
il devrait y avoir d'autres arrestations
beaucoup plus nombreuses dans la nuit
merci charles enderlin de ces précisions
la viande de lionel jospin en provenance
de gaza devrait atterrir à paris vers
21h le premier ministre qui aura donc
décidé en milieu de journée
des courtes et de quelques heures son
voyage au proche orient sans doute pour
raisons de sécurité
annulant ainsi la visite prévue dans un
conte de ré
juges et palestiniens à une journée
mouvementée ponctuée après les incidents
autour de l'université d'une conférence
de presse aux côtés de yasser arafat
j'ai vite albert chaque gregor le
cortège de lionel jospin a quitté bir
zeït sous les jets de pierres et dans
l'affolement général est que kilomètres
plus loin
le calme est revenu les voitures
s'arrêtent et le premier ministre vient
raconter sa version des faits vécus
calmement même s'il convient avec un
toit un des bars dans les airs site et
puis après tout ce sont ces cas là il
faut simplement aller au devant des
choses élèves activité sereinement
il avait été blessé non et vous allez
poursuivre votre voyage sans jugement la
visite continue donc dans une ambiance
bien différente s'il yasser arafat
accueil lionel jospin à gaza l'étreinte
et encore plus appuyée que de coutume
un geste qui ont dit long sur le
sentiment du leader palestinien après ce
qui vient de se passer
un peu plus tard au moment de la
conférence de presse commune est alors
que l'on découvre que le premier
ministre a bien été touché à la tête
semble-t-il par un jet de pierres
première yasser arafat s'exprime sur les
incidents à belgrade à le laisser à
d'amd présente mes excuses les plus
sincères pour s'effacer chad et je vous
prie de les accepter en mon nom et en
celui du peuple palestinien mais menée à
gaza
la police palestinienne n'a rien laissé
au hasard les lions étaient quadrillées
changement de programme pourtant la
visite que lionel jospin devait
effectuer à rânes younes un camp de
réfugiés où la colère risque est là
aussi de s'exprimer est annulée à la
dernière minute
cet après-midi la france signe en faveur
des territoires palestiniens le
déblocage d'une aide de plus de 100
millions de francs
le climat reste bon ici on veut oublier
la petite phrase de lionel jospin
je dirais que peut-être c'est parce que
la france a un rôle plus important dans
le processus de paix que c'est vers là
france que les chaumes ont été dans
l'explosion la l'année
la plus violente la plus intense la plus
passionnelle s'il avait été le premier
pour ce match je pense que perçoit de se
mélanger pour aller a brignais lui
lançaient des pierres yasser arafat a
tenu à accompagner lionel jospin
jusqu'aux marches de son avion l'ultime
geste d'amitié destinée à faire oublier
les violences de bir zeït une façon
aussi pour les deux zones de dire que
l'amitié franco palestinienne reste
forte malgré tout ce sera le dernier
message
une visite dont les conséquences n'ont
pas fini d'être mesurés et à paris
jacques chirac aussitôt informé des
incidents de la matinée a fait savoir à
lionel jospin qu'il avait été choqué par
ces incidents regrettables qui avait
marqué son passage à l'université de
birzeit le président de la république
qui désignèrent demandait au premier
ministre par voie de communiqué de le
rencontrer à son retour en france nous y
reviendrons dans un instant mais d'abord
voyant les nombreuses réactions
politiques qui se sont multipliées tout
au long de la journée dans l'opposition
comme dans la majorité en condamne
unanimement les actes de violence dont a
été victime lionel jospin mais à droite
tout en condamnant la violence
on est divisés sur les propos tenus
jeudi dernier par le premier ministre
albrand milk aussi même si la visite de
lionel jospin s'est donc terminée à gaza
dans des conditions plus sereines
l'émotion est vive ce soir dans la
classe politique française
unanimes pour condamner les incidents de
l'université de bir zeït souvent les
extrêmes utilisent des propos et utilise
ce déplacement pour assombrir le
processus de paix qui est engagée dans
le prochain rien je voulais d'emblée et
ça me semble important quand même
exprimer mon émotion et ma réprobation
[ __ ] est ma réparation totale devant les
actes de violence qu'a subies le premier
ministre et à travers lui je crois la
france la phrase de lionel jospin sur
les attaques terroristes du hezbollah
lors de cette conférence de presse
avant-hier et plus diversement appréciée
dans l'opposition peut distinguer deux
tendances ceux qui approuvent le premier
ministre se trouve à démocratie libérale
la france doit être partout il est
normal il a bien fait de maintenir à la
fois son voyage à la fois le dialogue
avec tout le monde mais encore une fois
pour maintenir le dialogue avec tout le
monde il faut être cru par tout le monde
et donc il faut dire la vérité ce qu'il
a fait la raison du côté du rpr voilà 24
heures que les prises de positions sont
beaucoup plus hostile après philippe
seguin c'est l'ancien premier ministre
alain juppé qui fait part de ses
critiques
le premier ministre de ce point de vue a
gravement dérapé et je voudrais insister
sur deux points d'abord condamné les
actes terroristes au sud-liban certes
mais il ne faut pas oublier de dire que
le sud liban est occupé depuis des
années des années par une armée
israélienne en contravention avec les
résolutions du conseil de sécurité
officiellement l'incident entre
l'autorité palestinienne et la france
est clos mais nul doute que les
événements de ce matin laisseront des
traces non seulement dans les relations
diplomatiques mais aussi au sein même de
la vie politique française
voyons à présent les retombées
politiques de ce voyage au cours duquel
il a neigé spa aura affiché sa propre
vision l'heure est aux explications avec
d'abord cette question gérard le caire
le premier ministre compte ils se
rendent dans les délais les plus brefs
à l'elysée on rentre jamais d'écouter la
réponse est non selon son entourage le
premier ministre n'entend pas répondre à
une convocation du président comme un
mauvais élève face à un instituteur les
deux hommes se verront comme d'habitude
mercredi avant le conseil des ministres
au mieux ce sauront-ils parler d'ici là
par téléphone le premier ministre compte
également s'expliquer mardi devant
l'assemblée nationale il entend assumer
pleinement ses propos qu'il relèvera une
ni deux la gaffe ou du dérapage mais dû
parler clair et réfléchie sans langue de
bois codé du quai d'orsay donc à coup
sûr la polémique va s'amplifier entre
l'elysée matignon est ce qu'on va
assister peut-être à une nouvelle donne
de la cohabitation
écoutez officiellement vous le savez
l'elysée on est resté d'abord au lourd
silence après les propos du premier
ministre puent au communiqué après les
incidents graves d'aujourd'hui mais les
proches et les soutiens du président
souligné deux fautes graves qu'aurait
commise de neil jospin d'une part en
empiétant sur les prérogatives du chef
de l'état en matière de politique
étrangère et d'autre part en ayant porté
un coup au principe d'une france qui
parle d'une seule voix donc à sa
crédibilité
efficacité de sa politique et c'est lors
d'un voyage pourtant minutieusement
préparée côté matignon on réfute la
notion de prérogatives présidentielles
le premier ministre a dit ont le droit
de s'exprimer et de définir la ligne en
matière de politique étrangère et sur le
fond rien n'indique jetons benoîtement
qu'il y ait une divergence avec le chef
de l'état sur cette question du
hezbollah en tout cas la cohabitation
vient de connaître non pas un simple
accroc mais je crois un tournant la
bataille dans la perspective des
présidentielles se déroule maintenant
sur tous les terrains y compris la
politique étrangère ou risque de
troubler les français attachés au bon
fonctionnement de la cohabitation et
notamment quand l'image de la france est
en jeu
merci gérard leclerc dans le reste de
l'actualité c'est terrible accident près
de nîmes où un groupe de cyclotouristes
a été littéralement fauché par une
voiture
le bilan est extrêmement lourd quatre
personnes tuées sur le coup dix sept
autres blessés dont plusieurs dans un
état grave
le plan rouge a été aussitôt déclenchée
le chauffard a été placé en garde à vue
karine comazzi denis par dan c'était un
peu moins de 100 parties de nîmes ce
matin pour une rando soleil sur les
petites routes gardoises
j'ai entendu un grand coup de frein j'ai
entendu un bruit énorme
j'ai cru que c'était plusieurs voitures
qui sont entre dedans mais quand je me
suis tourné que j'ai lu les cyclistes
parce que je les ai entendu arriver ils
parlaient entre eux je les entends y
arriver et quand j'ai vu des gens qui
monte en l'air des vers au dessert des
guidons j'ai compris que l'aérés
massacre le temps que je sorte de suite
ma femme était noire portée des draps et
où ils ont domaine de la glace parce
qu'avec un personnel et perdu sa jambe à
quatre hommes sont décédés 17 autres
blessés dont cinq grièvement
le plan rouge met en place très
rapidement par la préfecture a perdu des
transferts par hélicoptère sur les
hôpitaux de la région
le jeune chauffeur contrôlés négatifs à
l'alcootest est quant à lui quasi
indemne sa voiture lancé apparemment à
120 km/heure sur la départementale a
percuté la queue du peloton arrive en
sens inverse
pour sa défense il dit avoir été gêné
par une voiture qui dépassait les
cyclistes cependant d'après les premiers
éléments fournis par les premiers
cyclistes eux-mêmes qui ont étaient
indemnes dans cet accident le véhicule
blanc la question oui il y avait bien un
véhicule blanc dont nous recherchons
d'ailleurs la conductrice puisqu'il
s'agit d'une dame et ce véhicule aurait
terminé son dépassement au moment du
moment de l'accident et ce qui
expliquerait peut-être que cette dame
s'est même pas rendu compte qu'il y
avait eu un accident de l'ariège le
témoignage de la conductrice sera donc
précieux pour l' enquête judiciaire
quant au jeune conducteur il a été placé
en garde à vue l'un des organisateurs de
la randonnée était en tête de peloton
quand il a vu la voiture arriver à vive
allure
quelques secondes après il était trop
tard je suis partagée entre tristesse et
la n2 du comportement de certaines
jambes qui qui se posent sur ce seul sur
la route et une fois de plus les
cyclistes paie très cher leur passion
pour le vélo en deux ans où il y avait
perdu quatre amis cyclistes sur les
routes du gard depuis ce matin ils
n'osent même plus compter hier
l'agression mortelle d'un chauffeur de
bus à roissy qui a été frappé à coups de
couteau sur l'aéroport alors qu'il
prenait son service
à la suite de la mort de cet homme de 37
ans d'origine tunisienne la corporation
est sous le choc
au terme d'une table ronde cette nuit
les chauffeurs de bus reprendrons le
travail demain matin à partir de 4h30
les suites du procès de l'abbé morel
avec tard hier soir lors d'un huis clos
partiel l'audition d'un des trois
adolescents qui a témoigné durant près
d'une heure évoquant les sévices sexuels
qu'il a subi dominique verdeilhan blaise
craignent huis clos partiel le public
est invité à sortir de la salle
d'audience sol reste les magistrats les
avocats les jurés et les journalistes
dans un silence total religieux la voix
d'un enfant de 15 ans se fait entendre
avec les mots crus d'un jeune adolescent
françois raconte d'abord les tendresses
ensuite les caresses enfin le viol dans
le bureau de la baie la scène dit
françois s'est déroulée trois fois c'est
dieu qui l'a voulu il m'a dit monsieur
l'abbé la déposition du jeune homme a
duré
une heure ils adorent et son directeur
il adorait son professeur et c'est
extrêmement difficile pour lui de venir
dire et répéter devant la cour d'assises
et il m'a violée
agacé irrité déstabiliser jean-lucien
morel tente d'interrompre françois tu
m'en dit il avec véhémence je n'ai
jamais fait de choses pareilles je peux
le jurer avec ce que tu viens de dire tu
m'envoies en prison lâche l'accusé
vers 22 heures l'audience est suspendue
les deux autres mineurs seront entendus
lundi dans la nuit trois silhouettes se
fondent dans la foule
reste alors en mémoire les mots d'une
blessure
trois nouveaux cas dus à l'épidémie de
listériose portant désormais à 26 le
nombre de personnes touchées il s'agit
de deux personnes âgées d'une femme
enceinte là aussi c'est la langue de
porc gelais qui est encore cité dans l'
enquête alimentaire de ces différents
cas la sécurité alimentaire qui sera
bien évidemment à l'ordre du jour du
salon de l'agriculture qui ouvre ses
portes demain à paris en attendant les
quelques 600 mille visiteurs qui se
presseront à la porte de versailles les
derniers préparatifs avec les premières
dégustations dans le concours général
agricole eric mézil
delphine de tri pour quelques heures
encore l'odeur de la peinture fraîche
supplante celle des animaux électricien
éleveurs se côtoient dans une ambiance
de bugs le mans et de coups de marteau
et chacun ça fait pour soi même ou pour
fignoler le stand d'un client
les avoir un esprit un peu début de
siècle des halles les petits marchés
c'est pourquoi nous avons des petits
cons voir ces bêtes à concours ont
voyagé en première classe à 4 5 dans des
camions pleins de paille
pourtant l'atmosphère de paris rend
certaines vaches nerveuse d'aidé police
ce qu'il préfère au salon s'est retrouvé
ses amis pour l'occasion il s'est même
acheté une casquette toute neuve chaleur
humaine qui est super gênant bien aux
loyers le cash coach et la famille une
bonne gueule le concours général c'est
pas comme le casse croûte de chez dédé
ici on ne tremble pas et les verts ne
sont pas en plastique les 850 experts
sérieux comme des papes ont déjà
commencé à goûter une sélection des
meilleurs produits au menu du jour 20
poulet noah et olives
le lieu de nif
y arriver
galler pas l'être
demain les premiers visiteurs admireront
comme d'habitude les plus beaux animaux
mais certains d'entre eux auront
sûrement envie de poser quelques
questions sur leur sécurité alimentaire
on dit que les absents ont toujours tort
ce n'est pas l'avis de certains éleveurs
qui ont choisi de ne pas être présent
concours général
cette manifestation leur est interdite
en réalité puisqu'il s'oppose au schéma
de sélection par insémination
artificielle préférant la méthode
naturelle reportage d'eric masi et
nadine picard dans le tout et voilà
rapide mais efficace
samson a officié c'est grâce à des bêtes
comme celle ci que elie l'appli
collectionne les récompenses prix de la
meilleure laitière au salon de paris
l'an passé puis consécration suprême
prix du meilleur troupeau montbéliard à
besançon pourtant aujourd'hui ces bêtes
sont interdites de salon à paris le
concours général n'autorise plus que les
animaux nés d'insémination artificielle
en pratique en voiture elle parce que le
mode de sélection des centres
d'insémination nous convient pas on leur
reproche d'essayer de ils font le
maximum de port-vendres des doses mais
pas pour faire des bons animaux comme on
les voudrait cet éleveur se bat contre
la sélection génétique imposé par
l'organisme responsable de la promotion
de la race l'upra montbéliard
pour faire face à son succès croissant
c'est la deuxième phase la plus exportée
l'upra met au point un modèle de
géniteurs idéal dont les descendants
seront plus productif en viande et en
lait le président de cet organisme
claude gaillard parcourt le monde en vrp
pour vendre des doses de semence
l'évolution de la race montbéliarde elle
passe par le testage et euros plus on
teste taureaux plus on aura le résultat
plus on aura le résultat plus on pourra
vendre des semences de qualité et un
taureau tester coûte environ de trois à
quatre cent mille francs
même si cet organisme doit rentabiliser
ses recherches génétiques et lila fille
ne veut pas d'une vache standardisés est
nécessairement plus fragile des vaches
avec des bonnes mamelles alors surtout
des vaches rustiques avec des bonnes
pâtes avec la muse on lâche parce que
aujourd'hui les techniciens et rigole
presque dow jones la barre de coupe une
vache quand même jour là je peux
l'envoyer pâture est et sud est créée
par tous elle arrive a réduit sa vie ils
ne sont plus qu'une poignée d'éleveurs a
pratiqué la monte naturelle
mais en concours les plus performants
d'entre eux rafle la majeure partie des
prix ça veut dire aussi qu'on peut plus
comparer aux autres et c'est ça qui nous
fait mal c'est malheureux à dire mais
bon si ce n'avait pas de résultats je
pense pas qu'ils auraient pensé nos
évasées en soignant ses bêtes
aujourd'hui
il y doit en avoir gros sur le coeur
pour lui elle ne devrait pas être au
village aujourd'hui mais sous les
lumières du salon aux états unis
l'acquittement de quatre policiers
blancs qui avait tué par balles à
l'immigrant guinée à cela provoque des
manifestations dans les rues de new york
stéphanois tenaires la colère prévisible
près de l'immeuble ou amadou diallo a
été abattu 250 manifestants réclament
justice
ils ne comprennent pas qu'un peu plus
tôt quatre policiers blancs ont été
acquittés pour légitime défense
l'histoire remonte au 4 février dernier
ce jeune guinéen de 22 ans quitte son
appartement
quatre patrouilleurs aperçoivent le
jeune homme est sans une menace sans
hésiter il tire quarante et une balle 19
atteindront amadou diallo un déluge de
feu alors qu'ils n'étaient pas armés
dans ce contexte tendu la famille
prêchent l'apaisement au nom d'amadou et
de son âme
je vous demande de payer nous continuons
notre lutte pour la joie de tous
la vie et l'égalité live je vous
remercie tous les parents d'amadou
diallo vont maintenant se tourner vers
la justice fédérale dernier espoir
d'obtenir cette fois ci une condamnation
des quatre policiers
la fin de la visite historique en egypte
du pape jean paul ii le saint-père qui
ce matin s'est rendu en pèlerinage au
monastère sainte catherine dans le sinaï
l'occasion pour jean paul 2 d'appeler au
dialogue entre chrétiens juifs et
musulmans
isabelle steiss de nick merlin
isolée dans le désert du sinaï en plein
coeur d'une terre musulmane se dresse le
monastère sainte catherine au lieu de la
foi juive et chrétienne
selon la tradition c'est sur une de ces
montagnes que moïse a reçu les dix
commandements de dieu
en arrivant ce matin pour cette première
visite d'un pape en ces lieux jean paul
ii accomplie donc un de ses rêves les
plus chers
marcher sur les pas du prophète mais
l'endroit est avant tout une forteresse
orthodoxe et ce n'est pas l'évêque de
rome mais un simple pèlerin que le
patriarche damian hausse et les 23
moines du monastère accueille en visite
privée des moines qui ont toujours
entretenu d'excellentes relations avec
les musulmans
on raconte même que le prophète mahomet
est à protéger l'endroit
le monastère un des plus anciens la
chrétienté en ferme de véritables
trésors
icône des manuscrits comme ses cibles du
deuxième siècle jean paul ii s'est
recueillie sera dans la chapelle du
buisson ardent où selon la tradition
dieu s'est révélé à moïse mais les grecs
orthodoxes tenait à marquer leurs
distances avec l'église romaine dont ils
sont séparés depuis le xiième siècle et
c'est donc à l'extérieur du monastère
dans le jardin des oliviers que jean
paul ii célèbrera une liturgie appelant
une nouvelle fois à l'unité des
chrétiens
jean paul ii a conclu sa visite en
egypte en renouvelant également son
appel à la paix entre chrétiens juifs et
musulmans
c'est maintenant en israël et dans les
territoires palestiniens
il doit poursuivre son pèlerinage dès le
mois prochain en espagne à vitoria cette
double manifestation séparés par un
cordon sous haute sécurité
d'à côté des milliers de nationalistes
et de l'autre des manifestants non
nationaliste les deux cortèges parallèle
protestant contre l'assassinât par le
thé à la dirigeante socialiste et de son
garde du corps qui ont trouvé la mort
lors d'un attentat mardi dernier à la
voiture piégée quelques affrontements
sans gravité lors de cette manifestation
les séjours linguistiques c'est bien
connu forment la jeunesse et plus d'un
million de jeunes français se disent
intéressés par ce programme
pourtant de nombreux abus se sont
multipliés ces dernières années
obligeant à nos fils de contrôle à
vérifier sérieusement les conditions
d'accueil
quand ça se passe mal et pour que ça se
passe mieux ces exemples croisés à
l'occasion du salon du salon expolangues
nabila taboury thierry breton voilà ce
qu'on nous avons appris alors yellow
black green blue red orange pink white
sachant que en effet pendant les grandes
vacances mais en rentrant première des
cours bâclé des installations sportives
vétusté de jeunes adolescents laissé
sans surveillance
pour les parents qui ont dû débourser
7500 francs la pilule a du mal à passer
et s'étaient livrés à eux mêmes
l'après-midi dans les rues chose que
nous les parents ne voulions pas on
avait payé en conséquence pour avoir
quelque chose qualité on s'est fait
avoir
chaque année plus de 500 mille francs
c'est surtout des enfants et des
adolescents partent en voyage
linguistique
une majorité d'entre eux choisi la
grande bretagne ce matin là au sud de
l'angleterre
la petite ville d'hastings accueille un
visiteur pas comme les autres
renault est inspecteur à l'office de
garantie des séjours linguistiques
il s'est invité à la table des [ __ ]
elle les autres de damien à lycéens
français savez vous ce que damien fait
le soir
êtes vous toujours en contact avec lui
mais fasse mal
en fait damien un téléphone portable
comme ça nous sommes toujours en contact
avec les séjours linguistiques sont
devenus une véritable industrie qui
brasse plus de 3 milliards de francs
chaque année la mission de renault
tester la motivation des familles et
surtout s'assurer que le jeune à sa
propre chambre et des sanitaires à sa
disposition
c'est au rythme en serez commence à se
voir au bout d'une heure on peut
constater le problème donc là à priori
ya pas de problème ça se passe
ça se passe bien pour damien renault
évalue également les enseignants et
leurs programmes son avis comptera pour
beaucoup dans la charte de qualité que
des livres l'office de garantie une
sorte de label auquel se soumettent 30
des 400 organismes existants
c'est encore peu mais cela marque au
moins le début d'une réglementation pour
ce secteur où sévissent encore trop
souvent des officines sans scrupules une
page médecine avec que cette de bonnes
nouvelles annoncées par la très sérieuse
revue britannique de 27 dans les pays
occidentaux les maladies
cardiovasculaires sont de moins en moins
de victimes grâce à une meilleure
hygiène alimentaire et aux opérations
anti tabac qui portent leurs fruits
reste que l'on pourra encore
considérablement amélioré ses
performances
reportage frédéric vion sylvain gauthier
nous sommes à l'hôpital de strasbourg
service de cardiologie
ici chaque jour près de 80 malades
beaucoup d'entre eux ont été victimes
d'un infarctus ou souffrent de maladies
coronariennes
une fois que les premiers soins ont été
apportés les malades doivent apprendre à
changer leurs habitudes de vie et
notamment leurs habitudes alimentaires
on retrouve de tout je crois que c'est
un menu très complet ils ont eu un peu
de sauce il ya ya pas beaucoup de celles
csn c'est régime sec
car en alsace comme dans beaucoup de
pays du nord
l'alimentation est une des premières
causes de maladies cardiovasculaires
dans le sud de l'europe
on mange plus d'huile d'olive de fruits
de légumes ici au contraire c'est le
règne du cochon de la bière et du gras
un trio infernal
normalement je serai bien effectivement
ils mangent beaucoup trop grand bonjour
beaucoup de charcuterie en fonction de
l'alimentation et bien il y aura plus de
cholestérol une pression artérielle
élevée plus de diabétiques c'est lié à
l'alimentation n'a pas de secret les
ennemis du coeur sont bien connus tabac
mauvaises graisses absence de sport mais
grâce aux messages de prévention les
malades commence à prendre leur coeur au
sérieux ils viennent à l'hôpital dès les
premiers symptômes
les gens arrivent plus précocément un
stade d'évolution de la maladie pour
laquelle on peut agir de façon plus
efficace que la sq au stade ait eu de
l'infarctus du myocarde
depuis quelques années les nouvelles
techniques permettent de déboucher une
artère sans même opérer le patient mais
surtout les services des hôpitaux sont
plus spécialisés donc plus performant il
y a quinze ans 20% des victimes
d'infarctus mouraient dans les 24 heures
un chiffre qui aujourd'hui a baissé de
moitié les chorales la quitte à
transformer ces dix derniers jours en
cimetière de dauphin la semaine passée
certains accusaient les techniques de
pêche utilisant les filets pélagiques
mais selon des scientifiques les
pêcheurs ne sont pas les seuls
responsables david bazié philippe dumas
alexandre devait êtes un scientifique
mais aujourd'hui c'est un enquêteur
acharné à la recherche du moindre indice
pour éclaircir le mystère victimes
le gentil flipper 400 dauphins retrouvés
échoués caractéristiques presque tous
des mâles suspect numéro un
les méchants pêcheurs et leurs filets
pélagiques qui ne veulent pas endosser
l'entière responsabilité du massacre des
gentils des méchants la sphère est un
peu trop simple pour un chercheur
alors ils examinent le maximum de
cadavres cela pourrissent dans une
déchetterie offre visiblement a souffert
souffert mais comment voulez-vous
déterminé à partir de ça qu'il s'agit de
tel type de peine ou tel autre type de
pêche
moi ça mais ça mais je suis désolé mais
je ne peux pas le dire
autopsie du sale boulot une odeur
pestilentielle l'équipe en est à son
100e dauphin les prélèvements d'organes
apporte d'autres hypothèses
les pêcheurs ne sont pas les seuls
responsables des nodules la voilà l'état
donc des animaux parce que si on trouve
des animaux mais si on trouve des
animaux avec des métaux lourds
tout ça c'est l'indication d'une mère
qui étaient parqués pas très saine donc
l'intérêt c'est de savoir si elle est
bien ce n est de savoir si elle ne l'est
pas pourquoi les laboratoire
départemental de mont-de-marsan
l'un des plus compétents en matière de
faune marine les microscopes révèle un
indice inquiétant
la présence d'un ver parasite qui
perforent les poumons des dauphins
effectivement il ya de quoi s'inquiéter
à mon sens c'est pas forcément hasard si
je veux dire tous les ans il ya un peu
plus d'animaux échoué sur nos côtes
pourquoi ce parasite at-il autant de
vigueur la série noire des autopsies
continue pour alexandre plus il en fait
plus ils soupçonnent la pollution de
l'océan
dans ce cas le dauphin pourrait être la
première victime sur la liste des
espèces une page sportive une médaille
en or pour le français raphaël poirée à
oslo lors des championnats du monde de
biathlon
il a remporté l'épreuve du 15 km départ
en ligne en 39 minutes trente et une
secondes et avec une seule faute de tir
le français âgé de 25 ans a devancé son
adversaire russe c'est la première fois
qu'il décroche un titre mondial dans sa
carrière et puis cette moisson de
médailles pour la deuxième journée des
championnats d'europe en salle
d'athlétisme
la française linda feria est devenue
championne d'europe du 60 m eur à gand
belgique
elle s'est imposée en 7 secondes 88
centièmes devant la tenante du titre
patricia girard
enfin muriel hurtis a remporté la
médaille d'or du 200 m en 23 secondes
six centièmes la soirée des [ __ ] sur
france 2 tout de suite après ce journal
il y a quinze ans que le secret les
restos du coeur aujourd'hui la
mobilisation est toujours au rendez vous
sur la scène du zénith ce soir une
quarantaine d'artistes de chanteurs de
comédiens les coulisses et les
répétitions comme un parfum d'avant-goût
olivier les nizza clara monteil moi je
file un rang
baratin on vous promettra pas aller
toujours du grand soir mais juste faux
l'hiver à manger voilà
[ __ ] des fier de l'être
40 artistes qui ne se comporte pas
toujours comme des enfants de choeur
jean jacques goldman francis cabrel
david hallyday alain souchon et tous les
autres du 8 au 17 janvier ils ont
sillonné les routes de france donné huit
concerts une tournée conclu au zénith
devant plus de 4000 personnes en avant
pour la soirée des [ __ ]
o o
trois heures de spectacle certains
diront et alors ils apposent à sur l'a6
et alors captain patrick est arrivé avec
son joli bateau
il
et
et alors
et alors et alors le mans nord est
arrivé avec son joli chapeau
l'aventurier
un joli bateau un joli chapeau et alors
et alors
il se fait
le grand saut
brosseau sens zorro le héros qui vient
en aide aux démunis comme lui
sans correction et puis le cd des
[ __ ] en 2000 sortira dès lundi un
petit événement les bénéfices sont bien
évidemment reversés à l'association
c'est la fin de ce journal je vous
rappelle le principal titre lionel
jospin prise à partie à ramallah en
cisjordanie le premier ministre attaqué
à coups de pierres par plusieurs
dizaines de manifestants
jacques chirac se dit choquée par ces
incidents regrettables les réactions
politiques se multiplient
le premier ministre attendue à paris
dans moins d'une demi-heure et qui
devrait rencontrer selon nos
informations le président de la
république qu'en milieu de semaine
prochaine
dans un instant la météo nathalie
rihouet 20h55 la soirée spéciale
[ __ ] en 2000
féru heures 50 le dernier journal
laurence ostolaza de master dans thé ou
café
catherine ceylac reçoit lé nadine et
marie trintignant midi des m a présenté
par paul amar j'aurais quant à moi le
plaisir de vous retrouver demain dès 13
heures je vous remercie de votre
attention
excellente fin de soirée sont français
tous